were you at all
envious jealous upset that a one-term
senator became a president and the
governor of illinois didn't where you
felt you were more qualified to be a
president than him
i would say i was more resentful than
jealous i admire his skill right you
know he's a he gave a great speech in
boston in 2004 that catapulted him look
i had a good relationship with obama we
were in politics together in illinois he
was not close but it was good it's
friendly you're both democrats we're
both democrats on opposite sides of town
we were both pretty much the same
generation coming up at the same time
both considered rising stars in the
1990s
and uh you know i became the governor
two years before he became
a senator so we were both on that
trajectory way up high you became
governor two years before he became a
senator yes so on paper you're you're
the guy
that should have the lead on running for
office more than him yes i think so and
i was a governor too and historically
governors are more apt to be presidents
than senators and fifth largest state
we're not talking governor of like
kansas right but you said resentful so
what caused the resentment the
resentment resentment was that
i truly believe that the resco issue was
used by obama david axelrod who used to
work for me and and i like axelrod look
it's politics are rough ass business
okay very obvious and you know people do
things to you
on a monday they stab you in the back
and they screw you but you got to work
with them on tuesday right and so you
build up a certain immunity to this now
when calamity comes on like it did to me
into my family at that level
it's a lot more serious
so but i think what they did was they
were dumping rescue on me making me the
guy who was closer to resco because the
feds were looking at rusco and
as obama's political aspirations were
rising and his presidential
hopes became more realistic
they were dumping tony roscoe more on me
and this was
a design and the media was all over that
and they were protecting obama and
screwing me
and there was sort of like an
affirmative action approach to this in
other words they were elevating him
and and making me wear all the negative
stuff and so i think that's what it was
it was more the resentment of how i was
being treated by my own party and by the
media as opposed to like a fair
assessment that both of us had some
misjudgments with a guy that we thought
was not the guy he turned out to be so
if you enjoyed this little short segment
from the podcast that we did here's
another short segment to watch or if you
want to see the entire podcast click
over here take care everybody bye-bye
[Music]